you care about me so you put me on
[ __ ] shark weed yeah yeah
like you see me into the sharks i
thought he said a shark tank
right with a shark tank talking to
people
trying to stop tyson ranchers
[Music]
welcome to hot boxing i'm zab judah and
i'm mike tyson
baby and i'm dana white and we're having
some fun
let's get into it so right so listen
dana man what's going on
epidemic slowing [ __ ] down uh what's
happening man
i i don't know what it didn't slow me
down we're doing
we're killing it right now and have been
through the whole thing but uh
you know it's it's a pain in the ass but
other than that our business is doing
just fine
so listen man i like the heavyweights
today i saw derrick
a real good question you see that fight
what's one of those did you see derek
lewis fight no i didn't see that fight
that was
the fight of the year heavyweights
knockout
knockout vicious mike tyson mike tyson
style knockouts
the second punch he hit him with oh you
know it didn't look like he hit him
that was awesome yeah you hit him with a
couple after two he was two with that
first
oh god them always the ones the second
and third punch they always
they do the most the most damage it was
when he he was out and he got hit with
two more when he was out
yeah man yeah kind of crazy yes i'm glad
i'm glad he's okay after that but listen
who are you looking forward to him
fighting
i want to see him fight the guy with the
russian last name the black guy big
stronger with the right yeah yeah yeah
um
rose and strike you're thinking of so
what else man what else who do you want
to have what fight do you want what
fights you want to see happen i mean a
lot of the fights that i want to see
i'm working on right now to happen you
know you know whaley zhang
you know our chinese world champion yeah
we we want her and rose namajunas so
hopefully
we can get that done exactly that'll be
a great fight
and if she beats rose namajunas
everybody wants to see her move up and
fight valentina shevchenko
which is another great fight yes but
listen roses that could be a walk-over
absolutely it's a great fight have you
so beautiful to be so vicious exactly so
beautiful
exactly beautiful little girl that looks
like if you saw her over there
exactly she's a badass we got to talk
about something else so
so zab can get in the conversation
i'm a big fan i love usc so at
um heavyweight what's one of your dream
acts that you like to see happen
uh well i mean the fight that everybody
wants to see stipe mioczyk is going to
fight francis
in gano but he already beat him right
yes he beat him once exactly stipe beat
him once so
we met and uh they're doing the rematch
and whoever wins
will fight jon jones at heavyweight and
that's what everybody wants to see
jon jones first fight at heavyweight
will be for the heavyweight title
against one of those guys john is it who
do you think he has a better chance
against
i don't know man it's hard to deny jones
i mean the guy has been
one of the best in the world you know
since he started
um but i mean you guys know better than
anybody moving up a weight class
especially with the big boys like that
um
it's tough to do but he's vicious he
carried the attitude and the power with
him
it's true i mean andy's so well-rounded
he's such a talented guy
freak athlete yes yeah there's gonna
come a time like a guy like the ghania
uh
they're gonna hit him yep and then we're
gonna say can they take the heavyweight
punches
because i'm gonna happen it's gonna
exactly right i agree with you they're
very aggressive too so they're gonna
they're gonna be able to lay hands on
them so we're gonna have to see we're
gonna see what they really have
um question how do you feel about
uh the ufc like like
like when these celebrity fights happen
when a ufc fighter fights a youtube
fighter or did that ever happen
yeah yeah yeah there's a kid right now
that's that's fighting that kid
uh jake paul that he uh one one of our
fighters who's retired but he's boxing
and he's a wrestler
he's boxing he's wrestling he's boxing
against him and this kid's a wrestler
and the guy has to wrestle with boxers
right yeah his way grubs well he should
box a boxer then
box a boxer but [ __ ] listen let's be
honest
jake paul isn't a [ __ ] boxer this
guy's a [ __ ] two kids
he be working hard though he's a great
friend
working hard i watch him i watch them i
see him i see them put it together
zab no [ __ ] i'm just saying
so you're saying you're saying he could
fight
yes all right there you go
that is a that is a very broad question
who can he fight
right when you say five minutes can he
fight
[ __ ] yeah can this [ __ ] guy fight
over him yes he can fight yes he can
fight
you know what i'm saying can this kid
fight now can he fight mike tyson tyson
this kid fight listen i get it you're in
a bad position right now because you
hang out with the kid you know him at
the gym and [ __ ]
you don't want to [ __ ] all over the
place no no no no no can this kid fight
you know one thing about me you know i
shoot
i shoot straight [ __ ] kenny fight the
boy could let me tell you about this kid
so the kid that he's going to fight is a
wrestler
you know a real good wrestler decorated
wrestler
but he's he's actually fought real guys
he
he's been a world champion in other
organizations
yeah but it's different though dana when
you're standing up and you you know from
wrestling and standing up and let him
hand fly
one thing i can't say about him he got
hands yeah he got hands
yeah yo you i i'm i'm not
joking he's got hands he's very excited
but i want to see him fight again
again yeah i know i'm interested too
yeah yeah so he talks a lot of [ __ ] oh
man he does
that's why that's why he got like 75
million views that watches them
everything yeah yeah
they watch them then i watch it for no
reason we're going to find out we're
going to find out here pretty soon yeah
yeah now let me tell you what i hope you
can bet on this thing because i'll
[ __ ]
i'll bet a million dollars oh here we go
he loses this [ __ ] fight they know
why he loses this fight
a million so i hope we can bet on this i
love this guy paul this guy look he got
that million dollars danny's not playing
look at this he he went crazy with it
okay so now we know how he feel about
the
the baby blue eye yeah yeah
so what else is up what else is that
what else we got that's it man i just
you know i just
went on vacation with my kids had a
great time and now
you go back to work we went to uh
jackson hole wyoming god that's what the
real rich people
the real can we can we we can't call
people rednecks no more right
but these are the real rich white people
oh this is an interesting place this
place
is so rich
that's what they breathed in they didn't
go there
let me
my kids love snowboarding i went there i
i hate the cold man i'm too old for the
cold i can't
i don't [ __ ] snowboard or do any of
that it's too cold we can't go here yeah
yeah cold yeah i can't do cold i moved
to california because i you know i'm
western
brooklyn but i can't i can't do no
coaching i got kids i'll do anything for
my kids
that's why i don't know right isn't that
so much fun out there what is it what
are you doing
but you can go out there you go horse
right now yeah yeah yeah in the summer
horseback riding yeah in the summer
there's all kinds of you know white
water rafting and
so in a wednesday night yeah winners
there's one thing you can do and that's
it
well your snowmobile too snowmobiles all
that [ __ ]
animals this see the eagles and all that
[ __ ]
it's a beautiful place that's what i
love to eat but i like it in the summer
not in the winter
you're spending more time in california
now or here i want to go back to here
california just got me i'm
so lonely over there you know i know i'm
getting working out and everything but
i miss lonely i need to be here where i
can hang out with my kids
and chill out with them right yeah yeah
yeah
everybody's just locked up out there huh
and i gotta come through with that but
just um
i i'm really i'm really lonely out there
because the family's here
well well we're out there too but it's
it's just
it's not like here we have our friends
here we understand we have
dab and then yeah yeah really weird
traveling the world seeing everything
seeing everything i'm trying to
travel to tennis but wait a minute i'm
trying to think of this um this
young this young lady name she's the
woman's she's a woman's fighter
somewhere i think she's asian ufc
fighter
willie jang the champion [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah whaley jean you could take some
punches
she's a bad girl no no no but wait a
minute she has a rival what's her
what's the other girl that'll be talking
about you wanna young jay check come on
man i'm tapped in
i'm tapping so i seen this one night you
know just just
just laying there watching them and then
they were showing like i like how you
put together where they showed the
knockouts of both people
i was like whoa there's to be some [ __ ]
tell me tell me
tell me about that fight yeah so that
last year was the fight of the year
fight of the year last year those two
went to war
uh joanna and jay check ended up getting
a hematoma
for her entire forehead came out to here
yes
kept fighting they both fought like dogs
i've seen that one time then uh in
boxing with um high scene rock band yeah
that happened one time right so that's
how hers was worse than his
yeah i seen that she had almost like the
whole head
yeah they're still willing to fight yeah
yeah and they still
went five rounds toe-to-toe non-stop
what were you thinking at that time
when you seen that i was going crazy man
i was going crazy during that fight it
was one of the
one of the best fights you'll ever see i
know there had to be like a moment you
was like
oh my god i hope nobody's going to ride
who can i call like the corner man
somebody stop the fight help him
you know i mean incredible i know that
had to be phenomenal they're two
both bad ass women man badass women
crazy women have so much courage now the
the women's fights are some of the best
man there's some of the best fights
right
yeah these women are super technical
tough and they have a huge chip on their
shoulder
it's almost like they feel like they
have to prove something yeah more than
the man
of all the shows you put on who's your
best guy that you'd like to see perform
i mean it's it's hard not to say conor
mcgregor i mean conor mcgregor comes out
and puts on a show
the world goes crazy the whole world is
buzzing when that's
going to come back and he's going to
knock this guy out they're going to
they're going to fight all the time i
mean is that
all time all the guys you have yeah it
has to be yeah
yeah i like kind of
and the pay-per-view yeah i get the king
of pay-per-view when it comes to that
top of the food chain and something
that's liquor too
what about khabib trying to talk him out
of retiring which i never do i never try
to talk people out of retiring but
this guy's the baddest dude he's the
best in the world right now yeah but who
can you
go beat everybody right yeah that would
happen
you guys tell me listen as professional
fighters do you guys feel like
listen he makes [ __ ] loads of money he's
made a ton of money and he feels like
he's
levels above all these guys he's already
beat some of the guys in the top
you know most of the top five what do
you do do you keep fighting
i don't think you're right i lose that's
who i am i fight for a little
fight a little j you got you got to be a
dog you know what as fighters
we sign up not for money we sign up for
championship for glory
yeah you know i mean like we want to win
foolish stuff
yeah like silly stuff now in real life
that makes no sense but doesn't make
sense
because when you do all those things
when that's what you're going after
the money happens the money comes with
it right right right
i think that guys that sign up well what
i found that guy that signed up just for
the dollar
they don't do good that's different yeah
yeah i agree with you they get knocked
out quick and they go out you know guys
that sign up where they're like yo i'm a
bad [ __ ]
i could beat everybody in it and they
don't play they go the longest you know
i mean
they were like yo i'm gonna fight
whoever money money gonna come money
and the fans love those guys the fans
love that [ __ ]
that's like a bee khabib is that kind of
guy to me you're
right yeah you're not wrong yeah he
takes on all comings at all time and
yeah i like that guy right there he be
getting it in
me too i hope i hope he sticks around
i'm trying
this is a beautiful day it is thank god
for this thing right here yeah
it'd be a rough [ __ ] day out here
without those things
he's still going to jimmy workout what's
that d still going now
you don't work i i got a gym right in my
office so
it makes it very easy i've been pretty
consistent for the last year
nothing else to [ __ ] do right me too
it's so easy for me to just get
all the whack with my weight yeah it's
so easy i eat a couple of some
meaty stuff and i think my ice cream
starts to go into effect and uh i'll be
well you've been doing [ __ ] man great
shape champion doing good man he been
doing good he
you know he he got his body in
tremendous shape he's okay
yeah he's killing him like he's still
looking good man i mean
like i see a lot of fighters like you
know you going to these 10 week training
camps i mean
even back then with me you're going
through these long 10-week
12-week training camps and you disfigure
your body to just you know
cut up chisel rock and then after the
fight wouldn't lose a draw
you just say some fighters like [ __ ] it
man
go to jail what happened because you you
don't go to the gym after you take off
you gotta go to the gym three times a
day when i'm training right so now i'm
not fighting i'm just doing chilling
around
anything i eat it's gonna put on some
health everything wow
a bubble gum spit water
gotta have that dedication going yeah
i saw a video on on instagram where
these dudes were driving down the
freeway
and you were running doing road work
down the freeway and they were filming
you
and uh how much did you run for that
fight i first did i did um
i did a mile and a half my first run in
there did a mile and a half
and then um my last running date i did
six miles
six holy [ __ ] oh that's legit
how old are you now 51 52 64.
54 years old and then got back in shape
and running six miles yeah
absolutely you're moving but i ran the
six but then i walked to three so that
was like nine and a half on the roadwork
i did
holy [ __ ] and he looked amazing in his
last fight against roy jones
i'm gonna go all out in this fight i
mean it's gonna work totally
the whole session just do it all how did
you feel in there did you feel good
i felt better than i anticipated yeah i
thought i would be a little nervous
than i was and i was really relaxed
how did you feel though you felt you
felt good during the fight you felt like
i felt like wow i could do some more i
could
punch more companies i could do this i
could do that and i said wow this is
interesting and i said well i want to do
it again
and i want to do what somebody i could
do go really i love it all out on
yeah yeah it made me it made me
interested in wanting to do it again
yeah roy said royce said your [ __ ]
power is still unbelievable
yeah you got to see him in the gym i
wanted to go to distance
i didn't want to knock nobody out and
all that that's what people expect i
wanted to go to distance
and stuff you got to see him in there
man you being there
you'll be banging stuff up man you're
looking good thank you
i'm happy for you yeah i was worried
about you you know they're going into
that thing so
i'm happy for you if there's anything
that i can do if there's anything in the
world
if there's anything i can do i can fight
that's all i can do what were your
thoughts dana him
when you heard mike was going to ring
the fight like lately
i didn't lie i called him i told him
it's crazy
first of all let me say this so somebody
asked me
i told him i didn't like it and then
somebody asked me publicly
about it at a press conference and i
said yeah
i don't like it i i you know there's
mike tyson
is super famous there's lots of other
ways for him to make money
i don't want to see him get punched in
the head so he feels sorry for me i can
make money he gives me a job
or what's that thing shark week shark
week so he really likes me he really
cares about
me oh [ __ ]
dana really cares oh god he really cares
about my well-being
he's gonna leave me i'd rather fight a
lot now i gotta be into a shark
oh he really cared about me this is true
this is exactly what happened so
i called him and said don't don't
[ __ ] do this man don't do this
whatever i said listen i i got you i got
you a tv show i got them shark week
they just feed them
i heard the day that he actually
wouldn't swim he was super pissed off
and
the whole crew was scared that day
because because mike didn't want to get
in the water with the sharks
and then they turned the boat off and
they both stopped rocking after i pulled
they're gonna get both stickers oh my
god i gotta go in the cage
getting both so i thought i've had a
shark eat me out of the cage
um claustrophobic in the cage
so then somebody asked me at a press
conference about it and i said listen i
don't like it
i i don't want him to do it and this and
that so then he called me he's like
he's like listen man you and me are
friends we've been friends for a long
time
i'm a grown-ass man if i want to [ __ ]
fight i'm going to fight don't don't be
[ __ ]
negative about my fight you know and i
said you know what you're right
you won't hear you won't hear a [ __ ]
peep out of me again but it's all good
for karen though like what did you think
when you when i watched the fight
yeah i i mean when i watched the fight i
thought he looked really [ __ ] good
you know but listen no forget that
though
just listen to this world listen to this
world i'm following my 54.
they wouldn't give me a hundred million
that's more than i got fighting them for
championship
didn't tell me no you know come on
please i'd love to fight you
i'd love to that's true though that's
true
hebrews
you know i love the guy i i just have
this thing man
when we when you get to a certain age
it's just tough to perform
at a level that you did when you were
younger and and there's no reason he's
he he can make money anywhere he can
make money doing anything but
he's not wrong i will admit it's you
know when you get offered that kind of
money it's hard to [ __ ] turn it down
to do something you've been good at your
entire life your whole life yeah yeah
yeah because i never thought about doing
all these years i could have done this
stuff
but then somebody said i said hey i can
get a charity i can make this
bigger than what it really was and
that's really why i wanted to do it
yeah michael's had a good man you care
about me so you put me on [ __ ] shark
weed yeah yeah
like you see me into the sharks i'm
throwing it with you
no don't fight no oh no get your head
into the shot
no dad dad i thought he said shark i
thought he said a shark
tank right shark tank talking to people
trying to stop tyson ranchers
no put him to sleep
they had to come away to tell them
nothing too aggressive the whole the
whole crew was [ __ ] terrified that
day
mike was so pissed
i'm [ __ ] crying right now oh my god
it's hilarious
i thought he said shark tank he's gonna
shock me hilarious
state of the ufc where you want to see
it go in the next few years
as the country in the world starts to
open up
go into more territories that we've
never been in
um right now we have three champions
from africa well two and and and uh
what's his name has the opportunity to
become a champion uh
heavyweight against stipe nganyo
and uh i want to do a fight in africa so
planning that whole thing out right now
and uh so you're in talks already you're
working
continue to to go into places that we've
never been and build the uh build the
brand and
build the sport and build new talent um
the furthest part of the world
when knowing that there's a place called
christian dakuna
the furthest part of the world fisting
the kuna yeah the furthest part of the
world um
you can't go no further end of the earth
end of the world
wow only i think only two and three
people lived there
wow chris i'm tristan the corner
it's two and a half day um boat ride
from
cape town south africa no [ __ ] yeah wow
most um the most israeli center the most
isolated place place in the world
consider the part of africa like an
african island i don't think so it's had
zone island
it has i i have to look at um
it's between i it's between south africa
and it's in the middle of india it's so
many it's in the middle of so many
different this is so
it's just some creepy [ __ ] but it's just
beautiful because these people nobody
know these people they don't have no
tunnels they don't know nobody
just imagine living in a town or a city
just known as the end of the earth right
that's kind of like you know what's
going on you can't go no further
right like like like this is it it don't
it don't it don't go nowhere else
there's only 200 people there
that's rough we grew up in a building
with 200 people in the building
that's rough that's scary no television
no radio
no electricity wow very little yeah they
have one whatever water system i believe
certain amount of electricity is a
certain parts of the area for a certain
time
it's just very um nomanic
pretty cool man pretty cool yeah [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'm no way i'm gonna stay with
dana and go to the ufc fights man
i'll take a pass on that place yeah and
um indonesia is somewhere
that's valley's pretty hot too i haven't
been to ballet yet
bora bora i've been to but i've never
been to ballet you've been to valley
no i've been uh what's the what's this
what's this down next to what's
next to indonesia fiji there's another
on the right next to indonesia
[ __ ] i don't know like malaysia malaysia
yeah
i've been here malaysia's down there by
thailand and yeah
thailand yeah it's been down there i've
been around here there's a lot of time
around there
um
thanks for having me where are you gonna
go right now when you leave us what are
you gonna do what are you gonna go right
back to work
yeah yeah
go to work every [ __ ] day i get to
work at 8 30 and i stay there until
seven at night every day
[ __ ] [ __ ] due diligence on your job
that's right
that's right gotta make dedication i
make the donut
vacation yeah dedicated to come on take
us out debbie
now we have it here with uh dana dana
white
thank you good to see you we outta here
i'm zab judah
and i'm mike tyson thank you dana for
the time here brother i love you thanks
for having me love you too man
thank you brother thank you people for
watching good to see you yeah yeah
hot boxing
you